foreign
[Music]
into multiple languages
um some of you might disappoint me
because when I say multiple languages in
China talking about spoken language it's
not programming languages today
um so since I'm basically going to spend
a couple of minutes telling you how
annoying it was to develop a shiny app
in multiple languages I thought I'd
start by telling you why it's actually a
worthwhile thing to do
so the vast majority of websites and app
not just shiny up are develop in English
the problem with this is that the vast
majority of people don't speak English
only around 2 and 11 people actually
speak English and that's a large number
of people to automatically exclude from
interacting with your shiny app
language selectors are becoming sort of
more commonplace in traditional web
development and we want to make sure
that shiny apps don't sort of get left
behind
having said that translate things shiny
up into multiple languages is not that
straightforward to do
so what I want to talk about today is
some of the small issues that cropped up
when we were developing
um a bilingual shiny app to present
Public Health Data
translation effects uh every single
component of your shiny app simple UI
element suddenly became reactive
Expressions that relied on a user input
there are a couple of packages out there
that help you to automate the
translation process but what we found is
that those packages typically only work
for a few of the most widely spoken
languages and that there are built-in
dictionaries typically didn't include
domain specific terms so when we were
developing our bilingual we built the
translation capabilities directly into
the app itself
and during the development process there
were a couple of seemingly small
problems that suddenly became much
bigger problems debate
and one of those problems was uh what we
thought was easy
ordering a factor for a barter okay so
most of you have probably come across
the fact that R in the absence of other
instructions will automatically sort
your character vectors and your factors
alphabetically however this doesn't
always make sense so in this example
here we have age group inequalities as
character strings and we might want to
sort them from young to old because
that's easier for a user a user to
interpret so for a single language this
is really easy right we just create a
factor and we explicitly set with Factor
levels
and we get a nicely ordered partner
the problem is that when we start doing
this with multiple languages it does
it's not quite so easy
first of all we can't rely on this
alphabetical ordering at all anymore if
we sort character factor in one language
and we start in another actually they're
still in different orders now so we
can't rely on alphabetical ordering at
all
we also don't want to have to manually
specify Factor levels for all languages
it's a little bit annoying if you have a
few words in two languages person if you
have hundreds or thousands of words in
multiple languages it is completely
unmanageable
so to solve this problem for our app
what we did was we ended up using it
sort of default or primary language for
everything related to data processing so
in our case uh we did everything in
English
and we explicitly set these Factor
levels in English only
for a barter example what that meant was
essentially creating two different
functions
one function to compute the breakpoint
for The X Factor again this is done in
English only based on our data set
we don't create this a second function
to compute the labels based on the
output from that breaks function and
from the user's voice of language
essentially we wanted to translate as
little as possible
so
I hope the the last few minutes have uh
convinced you that translating Chinese
although it's not straightforward it is
a very useful and worthwhile thing to do
uh what we found our sort of biggest
lesson was that when we were building
this app translation was always the
first problem that we actually had to
think about if we wanted to add
something new but to keep her up
actually efficient it was always the
last one I thought I hope it's been
useful
find me on Twitter if you want that
[Music]